bonsoir à tous Arnaud Montebourg et
l'invité de Preuves par 3 le nouveau
rendez-vous politique que vous propose
publique Sénat député socialiste et
président du conseil général de
Saône-et-Loire et grand architecte des
primaires qui amèneront à la désignation
du candidat socialiste pour 2012 Arnaud
Montebourg bonsoir
trois séquences vont rythmer cette
émission c'est pour ça qu'elle s'appelle
preuve par 3 dans un instant notre
confrère de libération qui fait un
carton en librairie David revaudalon
avec petit meurtre entre camarades sera
là pour vous interroger puis ensuite
Perrine Tarneaud deux publics Sénat pour
des questions peut-être plus
personnelles d'abord Arnaud Montebourg
le climat politique qui se tend pour
l'exécutif confronté à des polémiques
multiples et puis à l'assaut aujourd'hui
la source généralisée du Parti
socialiste épisode le plus récent sur
les retraites est-ce que l'opposition
aussi elle est nerfs à vif
l'opposition fait son travail d'abord
parce que nous considérons nous n'avons
pas pu discuter suffisamment du texte de
loi sur les retraites je rappelle qu'en
2003 il y a eu 5 semaines de débat là
c'est une réforme d'ampleur beaucoup
plus importante avec plus de 20h pour
vous exprimer des avons eu une semaine
c'est à 5 fois moins pourquoi parce que
la réforme de 2008 a contribué à
bâillonner le Parlement le mécanisme en
est très simple il y a un temps
guillotine maintenant c'est à dire que
le pouvoir décide du temps de parole de
l'opposition donc quand Monsieur Sarkozy
et ses hommes le gouvernement décident
que ce sera 20h ou 19h50 pour les 200
députés socialistes et bien ce sera
19h50 et pas plus après la guillotine
tombe donc nous sommes opposés à cela et
nous avons dit nous avons encore des
choses à dire il y a des choses qui
n'ont pas été débattues la retraite des
femmes les polypensionnés la fonction
publique etc etc donc ce débat n'est pas
terminé il est d'ailleurs j'allais dire
il n'est le texte n'est pas soutenu dans
le pays
l'unanimité des organisations
l'unanimité des organisations syndicales
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion monte
qu'il est ultra minoritaire c'était un
texte injuste et injustifié alors vous
allez au-delà quand même de la simple
critique de la réforme des retraites
dans cette séquence de très haute
tension Arnaud Montebourg puisque vous
estimez que la République est abîmée par
qui d'abord quand
se multiplient un certain nombre
d'anomalies qui deviennent des
dysfonctionnements qui eux-mêmes sont
des inégalités c'est-à-dire finalement
l'État de droit est toujours dit piétiné
par le pouvoir nous en avons eu un
exemple à notre égard nous avons été un
certain nombre 156 députés qui n'avaient
pas eu l'occasion de s'exprimer dans les
bas des retraites qui ont demandé à
exprimer leurs droits de vote pourquoi
ils allaient voter contre et de donner
parce qu'on appelle l'obstruction
l'obstruction ça supposerait que on est
déjà eu six mois de discussion et que on
veuille faire traîner mais là
moi j'ai même pas pu m'exprimer
pourquoi c'est allé en même pas une
semaine ça c'est pas destruction c'est
un droit à constitutionnel qui vient
d'être piétiné par le gouvernement et le
président de l'Assemblée nationale a
demande du pouvoir exécutif ce qui est
quand même un problème car le Parlement
n'est même plus défendu par son
président donc maintenant nous sommes
dans une situation où les
contre-pouvoirs sont systématiquement
écrasés la presse fait l'objet d'enquête
du contre-espionnage au mépris
d'ailleurs des règles de protection de
la des sources des journalistes au
mépris des règles qui fixent des
missions au service secret qui
s'occupent de terrorisme et d'atteinte à
sûreté de l'État mais certainement pas
de devoir se transformer en détective
privé pour le compte de ministres en
difficulté judiciaire et en délicatesse
avec leur comportement personnel ça
c'est pas possible mais ils le font les
juges sont aujourd'hui mis sous le
boisseau c'est à dire contrôler par le
pouvoir et utiliser
à des fins politiques ce qui s'est passé
dans la faire cuire stream ou pour
régler des comptes avec un rival de
Villepin on a utilisé la justice pour
faire condamner
puisque vous dites aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes plus en état de droit mais nous
avons un état droit qui est piétiné tous
les jours d'ailleurs regardez ce qui se
passe avec les Roms vous avez des
institutions morales le pape les
archevêques les institutions
juridico-politiques le Parlement
européen la Commission européenne
l'ONU et un haut-commissaire au droit de
l'homme et aux droits fondamentaux de
l'ONU c'est à exprimer son émotion et
qui explique les conditions dans
lesquelles la France s'est lancé dans
une dérive discriminatoire est-ce que la
commissaire franchement à vos yeux un
moment de Bourg est allé trop loin en
faisant le parallèle avec avec la
déportation et la Seconde Guerre
mondiale moi je pense qu'elle a posé non
non elle a mis le doigt sur un vrai
problème d'abord avant l'un des
portations des Juifs
il y a eu des mesures discriminatoires
acceptables l'alimentation des Juifs
elle est venue 10 ans après les
premières mesures discriminatoires on
commence comme ça donc faut savoir
s'arrêter mais où est-ce que ça vous
osez ce parallèle et je n'ose pas parler
tout le monde a compris que dans notre
pays on a une histoire ou la
discrimination
juridique a été menée par un État qui
s'appelait Vichy
15000 personnes ça concernait 15000
personnes on peut s'en moquer allez
d'ailleurs vous prenez la circulaire de
qui a été abandonné par le pouvoir vous
remplacez le mot
Rome par le mot juif mais là s'il savait
était le cas on aurait poussé des
hurlements et des hurvaris pourquoi
parce que il n'y a plus d'appréhension
de la responsabilité individuelle en
fonction du comportement individuel mais
il y a une politique en fonction du
comportement supposé d'un groupe en
raison de son origine c'est la violation
de la Constitution l'article 1 question
des Roms vous savez que personne n'est
tout à fait à sur le sujet c'est un
dossier embarrassant y compris pour les
élus socialistes par exemple François
Rebsamen il justifie lui le
démantèlement des camps et il va même
jusqu'à justifier leur envoi dans dans
leur pays d'origine mais il y a une
attitude qui consiste à dire il y a des
problèmes dans certains endroits il y a
des problèmes où il y en a pas il y a
des endroits où il y en a pas donc ça
veut dire que on considère que la
question n'est pas celle des Roms mais
d'un certain nombre de campement qui
dans certains cas posaient problème dans
d'autres pas je rappelle qu'un certain
nombre de démantèlement de camps
illégaux illégaux ont été
annulés par la justice donc il ne s'agit
pas de cibler pour des raisons de
calculer électoralesordides une
catégorie en raison de son origine ça
c'est inadmissible et c'est interdit par
les principes constitutionnels on ne
peut pas le faire c'est interdit donc
comme Madame reading dit ça ressemble à
ce qu'on a connu avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale elle fait allusion au
fait que quand on cible des catégories
de population en fonction de leurs
origines on commence par en quelque
sorte isoler ces gens et monter la
population contre eux donc c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive une sorte de racisme
d'État ou quelque sorte d'officiel
c'est toujours bon enfant mais ça peut
être très mal se terminer votre réaction
Nicolas Sarkozy et scandalisé par le
parallèle qui a été fait par Viviane
reading avec la déportation des Juifs et
aujourd'hui il lui a conseillé et bien
de prendre des Roms dans son pays
d'origine le Luxembourg comment est-ce
que vous réagissez la commissaire cette
déclaration du chef de l'État devant les
MP la commissaire européenne s'est
exprimée comme institution de l'Europe
qui a un état de droit auquel nous avons
souscrit et ce qu'a dit Madame la
Commissaire c'est qu'elle allait
proposer une procédure d'infraction
contre la République française
nous n'avons pas de recours nous nous
sommes dans un pays où pourquoi vous
vous posez la question de l'État de
droit pourquoi l'État de droit est en
train de disparaître
nous sommes dans un pays où parce qu'il
faut
pour chasser des gens qui en raison de
leur origine sont supposées être
coupables alors qu'ils peuvent
parfaitement être innocents je parle des
Roms et parfois il faut innocenter des
gens qui sont supposés en raison de leur
qualité ne jamais être coupable c'est le
ministreur par exemple alors on protège
non je considère qu'ils ne devrait pas
être au Parlement plus longtemps et
qu'il devrait répondre de ses actes
devant la justice avec ses avocats pour
défendre son honneur voilà donc quand
vous avez un ministre qui lui-même étant
situation d'être ultra protégée par le
pouvoir on utilise un procureur qui
organise la confusion pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'affaires à son sujet on va
chercher une inspection générale
spécialement pour lui pour faussement
l'innocenté on va chercher les services
secrets pour décourager des journalistes
d'obtenir des informations sur lui voilà
ce qu'on fait pour protéger quelqu'un
qui semble-t-il a commis de graves
indélicatesse en revanche on a quand
même des innocents
parce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont on ne
sait pas il y a des robes sont tout à
fait honnêtes ils sont même français
vous dire et qui habite très
tranquillement en toute légalité
légale il y a beaucoup d'annulations des
tribunaux administratifs et il y a une
procédure sanction de l'Union européenne
alors ça suffit pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
la France
et l'état de droit dans la République et
placer en danger par celui-là même qui
est chargé dans l'être le garde le
président de la République vous vous
adressez directement à lui qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de lui que lui demandait
mais nous n'attendons rien du président
de la République pourquoi parce que il
est la cause des problèmes de la France
une solution un nouveau départ est-ce
que vous espérez un nouveau départ avec
un changement d'envergure comme vous
l'avez compris les ministres eux-mêmes
sont souvent des possédés de leur
prérogatives puisque les pouvoirs ont
été transférés au conseiller de l'Élysée
monsieur Guillon a plus de pouvoir que
Monsieur Fillon Premier ministre donc le
problème c'est que
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions que
finalement
attendre les élections 2012
Aymeric et ces élections sont anticipées
c'est pas votre cas la dissolution
de la République nous est pas accessible
vous comprenez c'est à dire que la cause
de nos problèmes sur le non
fonctionnement de l'État de droit et le
dysfonctionnement de la République et le
piétinement de cet État de droit c'est
le président de la République lui-même
donc toute initiative qu'il pourrait
prendre en dehors de corriger son
comportement et sérieusement et pour
longtemps concrètement il ne réglerait
aucun comportement vous lui demandez
d'adopter précisément par exemple en
Suède je prends trois exemples comme ça
au hasard 3 si ça vous dérange pas en
Suède pour faire la réforme des
retraites qui a été approuvée par
l'opposition à la majorité il y a une de
très très longues discussions mais on
est arrivé un compromis final donc ça
demande du temps du respect et puis
finalement de la bonne foi ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas en l'espèce
puisque le gouvernement raconte
n'importe quoi pour essayer de manipuler
l'opinion sur la question de toute la
vérité sans déni de réalité je vais de
vérité je le crois sincèrement puisque
nous sommes dans une dans la défense
d'une contre-proposition et nous
construisons sur cette
contre-proposition la crédibilité de
notre
éventuelle
l'autre exemple on pourrait imaginer que
par exemple sur la question
des Roms il est construit une politique
en rapport par exemple avec la Roumanie
la Bulgarie
trouvant des solutions concrètes avec
les élus locaux par exemple on pouvait
imaginer des solutions concrètes avec
dans le consensus le compromis tout ce
que vous dites là c'est propositions ça
ne montre pas que l'État de droit est en
danger mais je voulais démontrer tout à
l'heure là ce que je vous dis c'est que
le problème c'est le comportement du
président de la République troisième
exemple que vous vouliez dire nous
pourrions imaginer par exemple plutôt
que chercher à bâillonner le Parlement
ou faire pression sur la presse en
utilisant les services secrets il
respecte scrupuleusement les règles par
exemple il pourrait dire puisque mon
ministre verte d'ailleurs tout présent
de la République l'a fait un jour à
l'égard d'un ministre en difficulté
judiciaire puisque mon ministre verte
est injustement accusé je vais lui
demander de se défendre je vais demander
à ce qu'un juge indépendant puisse faire
le travail et donc au procureur de la
République puisqu'il a le pouvoir donner
des ordres directement de nommer une
instance judiciaire indépendante devant
laquelle monsieur Burt pourra défendre
sa position éventuellement obtenir
quelques réagissez ça c'est le respect
normal des institutions les institutions
et que vous entendez dans les bandes de
l'opposition crier le nom Mitterrand
Mitterrand mais moi je vais vous dire je
pense pas qu'ils étaient hors car
Mitterrand enlève dans l'affaire des
écoutes a commis grave infractions mais
au moins elles ont été poursuivies
celle-là et d'ailleurs je me souviens de
Pierre Jacques l'un de mes grands aînés
dans Saône-et-Loire qui avait témoigné
c'est un très proche de Mitterrand qui
avait témoigné à la barre du tribunal
correctionnel pour dire j'ai des
approuvé ce comportement donc moi je ne
me sens pas du tout solidaire et je peux
condamner rétrospectivement tout ce qui
s'est produit à cette époque ce sont là
de graves dérapa et ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils ont eu lieu qu'il faudrait qu'il
se reproduise au contraire c'est par
l'expérience qu'on peut aujourd'hui
savoir que tout cela peut aller très
loin
vous demandez toujours la démission de
Bernard accueillez vous accusez de
forfaiture le président de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la seule démission que
vous réclamez d'abord je vais vous dire
il y a des députés de non inscrit S qui
sont intervenus qui se sont plaints du
comportement d'accoyer qui a violé
règlement
donc sur tous les banques chez Bayrou
s'est porté au secours physiquement dans
l'hémicycle tout à l'heure auprès de
Monsieur Daniel Garric député de la
Dordogne non inscrit ancien UMP qui a
rompu depuis que Monsieur Sarkozy étant
dérive donc la droite est en train de se
désagréger Monsieur François Goulard
c'est porté physiquement au secours
monsieur Gary parce qu'il n'obtenait pas
le droit de parler donc vous ne croyez
pas que tout cela ne provoque pas des
ondes de choc importantes et y compris à
l'intérieur de lui bien sûr Arnaud
Montebourg je vous le disais vous êtes
je le rappelais vous êtes l'architecte
des primaires décisives en vue de 2012
David Revault expert SPS va nous
rejoindre dans une minute mais d'abord
votre nouveau tropisme ah oui vous le
connaissez Arnaud Montebourg votre
nouveau tropisme américain Marie Brémond
il chante à tout va son rêve français à
la sauce américaine America America
c'est le refrain car nos Montebourg
tente d'imposer aux parties socialiste
depuis quelques temps le monsieur
rénovation du PS imagine rassemblant les
foules autour des urnes pour choisir le
futur candidat de la gauche vous avez
remarqué que chez nos amis américains
c'est encore lui le fan absolu du Made
In You essaie que l'on retrouve au côté
des Obama boys venus spécialement à La
Rochelle expliquez l'avantage de
primaire très très ouverte les
Américains ont réussi après
l'effondrement du Parti démocrate à
reprendre pied dans la société
américaine et mettre en mouvement la
société américaine pour qu'elle
s'approprie la victoire de Barack Obama
c'est exactement la même stratégie que
nous suivons déjà il y a 10 ans
l'électron libre du PS alors young
leader était reçu en teriyanki et c'est
toujours inspiré par le modèle
outre-Atlantique car le monde bourre
avance aujourd'hui son pacte de
tranquillité
c'est l'association de la population et
les habitants eux-mêmes à la lutte
contre les délinquance à force de rêver
d'Amérique le député de Saône-et-Loire
risque d'en perdre son français Arnaud
Montebourg aux États-Unis en octobre
pourra peut-être échanger sur le sujet
avec le Français résidant à Washington
Dominique Strauss-Kahn
bonsoir David Renaud
journaliste à Libération et auteur donc
de ces Petits meurtres entre camarades
les primaires est-ce pour stopper ou
relancer le phénomène de ces petits
meurtres internes à vous de poser les
questions David bonsoir Arnaud
Montebourg j'ai envie de rentrer dans le
vif du sujet et vous êtes l'architecte
de ces premières mais vous en êtes aussi
l'un des acteurs potentiels majeurs
j'ai donc je vais donc vous poser cette
question est-ce que vous avez
l'intention d'être candidat
à ses primaires qui auront lieu dans un
an à l'automne 2011 c'est une réflexion
que j'ai ouverte et engagée vous
comprenez bien que c'est quand même tôt
pour le dire puisque
nous ne connaissons pas l'état de
l'offre politique moi vous savez j'ai un
itinéraire de rénovateur c'est Monsieur
avec parfois comment dire obstination
peut-être excès de passion
pour implanter des idées nouvelles dans
la gauche ça a commencé avec les paradis
fiscaux nous avons continué avec la
Sixième République il y a eu beaucoup de
sujets sur lesquels nous avons essayé de
modifier la gauche et de la faire se
transformer donc cette question elle est
encore
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre parce que la
rénovation ce n'est pas un changement
seulement de procédure c'est aussi la
transformation de l'appréhension des
principaux problèmes de notre société la
question de l'insécurité la question de
la mondialisation les problèmes de
financement de l'État évidence la montée
du racisme dans notre pays comme on
fait-on il y a beaucoup de questions que
la gauche aurait intérêt à s'approprier
donc moi si je me je veux dire je
m'interroge c'est en raison de la
nécessité de faire avancer toutes ces
idées qui depuis des années dorment
dorment injustements dans certains
cartons un peu trop vastes justement on
sent dans ce que vous dites que vous
avez vous préconisé une solution
générationnelle un coup de un coup de
jeune très clairement je suis pas sur
cette ligne là je pense que c'est une
question de proposition politique et de
force évidemment pour les porter je ne
crois pas que là je sois une garantie je
ne crois pas en tout cas je pense qu'il
est nécessaire que nous changeons de
méthode et d'ailleurs c'est l'esprit des
primaires votre reportage un petit peu
taquin faisait allusion à nos relations
amicales et même très suivie avec les
Américains qu'est-ce que les Américains
ont fait ils sont appuyés sur la société
pour la changer nous à gauche on
s'appuie encore sur la vieille forme
d'appareils avant-gardiste d'esprit
léninistes c'est-à-dire qui a la science
et la conscience à la place du peuple et
qui lui guide son chemin c'était
l'esprit de la révolution russe n'est ce
pas c'est à dire que on avait tracé le
chemin des masques qui se sont ensuite
engouffrés dans le plébiscite et
l'approbation de de la Révolution anti
tsariste nous pensons le contraire
c'est-à-dire que dans une société
aujourd'hui qui est en train de se
déliter avec
la montée de l'individualisme on a
besoin de raccrocher en quelque sorte
les wagons de chaque individu à
l'intérêt public donc il faut s'appuyer
sur la population et y compris sur ces
demandes et c'est pourquoi
par exemple en matière de sécurité par
exemple
justifiées j'ai fait une proposition par
exemple je disais nous pouvons
parfaitement associer la population pour
avancer sur la question de la sécurité
pourquoi parce que les angéliques comme
on dit c'est à ceux qui cherchent des
refuge qui dit c'est d'abord l'économie
sociale qu'il faut traiter avant Parti
socialiste non pas seulement je crois
que il y en a partout il y a d'ailleurs
c'est une des raisons aussi la montée de
la délinquance la progression de la
misère et puis aussi les ultras
surenchérissent ultra sécuritaire tout
le monde a échoué donc si tout le monde
a échoué il faut que maintenant on
trouve d'autres solutions donc la
propulsion que j'avais faite à frangipe
puis ensuite je le referai dans le forum
sur la sécurité du Parti socialiste
c'est
d'associer la population aux enjeux de
la lutte contre la violence c'est-à-dire
que chaque adulte est chargé à sa
manière d'une parcelle de
responsabilité publique ce qu'on fait
les policiers de Chicago dans les années
80-90 avec des résultats ils ont associé
tous les mois les policiers discutaient
avec la population et associer à la
population à leurs enjeux et partager
leurs problèmes en disant là on a raté
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comment on
améliore et finalement tout le monde
s'est retrouvé en quelque sorte qu'au
responsable la situation alors ça c'est
l'exemple de la stratégie ce que je veux
dire aubameyène
vous parlez d'associer la population
première question comment vous faites
pour faire participer des centaines de
milliers voire des millions d'électeurs
assez primaires puisque c'est un peu
l'exemple italien je crois qui était une
aussi à par exemple américain de veau
une de vos modèles et comment vous
faites si vous vous retrouvez avec 200
000 participants et deuxième question
est-ce que vous allez pas vous
socialiste vous sentir un petit peu seul
dans cette primaires dans la mesure où
ni les écologistes ni des communistes ni
les chevaux de mantistes ni les
mélenchonistes ne vont y participer
vraisemblablement d'abord je ne crois
pas du tout à votre prédiction
toutes les angles
je ne donnerai pas kiffe ce qu'on ne
peut pas donner mais moi je suis je
pense que je peux vous dire mon
sentiment toutes les enquêtes d'opinion
ont montré parmi les sympathisants de
gauche un grand désir de participer et
aujourd'hui je crois que 30% de
l'électorat actif qui va voter c'est
déclaré sur et certains d'aller voter à
des primaires si elles étaient
organisées ce qui donne
plusieurs millions plusieurs millions
donc c'est considérable donc ça c'est la
première le premier élément d'optimiste
pourquoi parce que le désir
de ne pas rester dans la situation que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui le désir
pas seulement d'alternance mais aussi
d'alternative et très puissant dans la
population il y a un désir d’autres
choses et puis aussi de retrouver la
paix dans ce pays puisque on est en
train de se faire la guerre partout le
pouvoir allume des foyers de discorde et
les aliments puisqu'il en a besoin pour
ses calculs électoraux donc ce choix de
retrouver la réconciliation de se
rassembler autour d'un projet de se
respecter les uns les autres laissez
l'esprit des primaires l'esprit les
primaires c'est aussi une culture tout à
l'heure vous dit est-ce que ça va pas
exalter à nouveau les divisions non
c'est non parce que c'est la police du
désamour les primaires c'est la police
des désaccords si je peux m'envoyer
cette expression un peu comment
parce que
on va pas faire la police des sentiments
mais c'est une manière de casque rose
c'est oui
c'était pour vous distraire un peu c'est
une manière de dire
quand on entre dans les primaires on
sait qu'on soutiendra le vainqueur même
si on n'est pas le vainqueur donc de
toute façon on va tous ceux qui vont les
primaires vont travailler à imaginer
l'après Sarkozy et après la parenthèse
Sarkozy ils vont travailler ensemble
pour faire le gouvernement et donc
traiter les problèmes des Français et il
y en a un paquet qui sont sur la table
qui sont les travers des socialistes
certes on constate une accalmie de la
météo en cette rentrée on l'a vu à La
Rochelle avec beaucoup d'images de
démonstration d'unité c'est très bien
mais les deux dernières années ont
montré que la guerre civile était quand
même permanente est-ce que vous par
cette ce processus déprimé qui la
compétition institutionnalisée vous
n'allez pas finalement paradoxalement
revenir à vos vieux démons et
transformer cette scène émulation en
sanglante confrontation je voudrais vous
amener à réfléchir aux raisons pour
lesquelles on a retrouvé une certaine
paix comme vous le disiez
c'est parce que les primaires sont là on
connaît les règles on sait comment ça va
se dérouler selon quelle formule il n'y
a pas à se battre puisque de toute façon
on sait que il y a ceux qui peuvent et
ceux qui peuvent pas donc finalement le
système est en train d'organiser le
tamis de l'histoire on se coupe et on
gardera les on regardera les meilleurs
c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne c'est
parce qu'on a la règle la dernière fois
on n'avait pas de règles chacun se
battait pour se positionner là la
situation est différente parce que
d'abord
on a nous-mêmes organisé les règles du
jeu donc ça un facteur d'apaisement
Arnaud Montebourg David revaudalon
évoque la nuit la plus glauque de
l'histoire du PS dans son livre c'est
votre expression c'était la lumière
c'est votre expression c'est ce que vous
avez dit la nuit la plus beau look quand
il a fallu dépouiller
les bulletins qui ont finalement porté à
la tête du PS Martine Aubry c'était en
fait la partie triche comme l'écrit
David alors est-ce qu'on peut vous faire
confiance en honnêteté électorale pour
les primaires
écoutez nous avons justement tirer les
leçons de cette triste période et je
veux lui rendre l'hommage à Martine
Aubry Ségolène Royal d'avoir su se
retrouver sur un dispositif que j'ai
proposé
assurant évidemment la sincérité la
transparence du scrutin c'est une
question très importante parce que elle
garantit finalement le bon achèvement et
puis la crédibilité du résultat
moi je pense que aujourd'hui un parti
qui joue en quelque sorte ses décisions
à un millier de voix avec des grandes
fédérations qui sont totalement
verrouillées féodalisés un parti qui
d'ailleurs a perdu beaucoup de sa
substance par rapport aux grands des
belles années et les divisions internes
ont fait beaucoup de mal nous avons
besoin de nous ouvrir et d'aller
rechercher la sève de la société la
faire couler en nous dans nos dans nos
dans notre troncs dans nos feuilles dans
nos branches David
vous allez je crois dans 15 jours à
Washington pour vous renseigner sur le
processus américain de primaire est-ce
que vous allez rencontrer Dominique
Strauss-Kahn et comment au-delà de cette
potentielle rencontre comment vous
situez-vous par rapport à son éventuelle
retour écoutez moi j'ai veillé à ce que
comme organisateur comme vous dites
architecte c'est un bien grand mot on va
dire inspirateur militant plutôt
militant avec la truelle c'est pas
architecte plutôt les mains dans la dans
le ciment
j'ai veillé à ce que tout le monde
puisse se situer dans le processus
Ségolène Royal Martin Aubry Manuel Valls
Pierre Moscovici même au besoin peu
importe Dominique strauss-kah tout le
monde
ça n'est pas prévu mais je pourrais le
faire je pourrais d'abord parce que il
est normal que nous nous discutions moi
je considère que il a toute sa place
dans le dispositif socialiste et nous
avons la chance d'avoir plusieurs
candidats qui aujourd'hui sont en mesure
de l'emporter donc il faut s'en réjouir
abondance de bien le nuit par justement
sur ces plus sur ces candidats à mon
danse de bien ne nuit pas je suis
parfaitement d'accord mais on a beaucoup
parlé de pactes ces derniers mois entre
différents candidats Martin Aubry
Laurent Fabius Dominique Strauss-Kahn
même Ségolène Royal semblait y
participer est-ce que finalement si
pactilia s'y accord il y a les primaires
ne sont-elles pas totalement vidés de
leur substance s'il y a un pacte ça veut
dire que les intéressés sont d'accord
donc s'ils sont d'accord ça veut dire
que il n'y avait pas de raison d'avoir
de débat entre eux le débat
je ne dirai pas ça parce que pas de
débat entre ces personnes parce qu'ils
sont d'accord sur les orientations et la
façon dont ils vont prendre les
problèmes de la France je rappelle quand
même que nous avons à restaurer la
démocratie faire muter écologiquement le
pays
réindustrialiser la France organisé la
réconciliation des Français faire en
sorte que tous les laisser pour compte
des dernières années soit j'allais dire
réconcilier avec le le vivre ensemble
c'est un boulot énorme plus
tenter de réorienter l'Union européenne
sans tendre avant non pas forcément je
pense que s'il y a des gens qui n'ont
pas des accords fondamentaux il est
normal qui se mette d'accord si ils se
mettent pas d'accord c'est qu'il y a des
désaccords sur la manière de voir les
choses donc le débat il aura lieu avec
des gens qui auront des vrais des
accords ça veut dire que les primaires
vont être des primaires de débats
démocratiques sur des orientations ce ne
sera pas un concours de vache landaise
très bien merci David
dernière séquence de préfare 3 avec
l'arrivée dans une minute de Perrine
Tarneaud de Public Sénat avant cela une
interrogation alors no mangour vos
adversaires vous reconnaissent du talent
mais dénonce souvent vos excès ceux d'un
procureur vous connaissez le reproche
terrain pourtant sur lequel vous êtes
aujourd'hui concurrencé tam-trans
monsieur Montebourg un garçon qui a du
talent à toujours été un peu procureur
de bistrot et il en a d'autres des
surnoms pour fendeur de la Cinquième
République Saint-Just fou qui est un
ville Arnaud Montebourg c'est le type
même du combattant acharné contre
l'immunité présidentielle et les paradis
fiscaux et le défenseur non moins
fervent du mandat unique bref un
révolutionnaire qui ferait bien table
rase pour une sixième république mais
attention il est peut-être en train de
se faire piquer la place par une
remplaçante de choc et va joli
l'ancienne juge anti corruption s'est
fait connaître par ses enquêtes musclées
et en embrassant la politique elle
n'hésite pas à rappeler son passé
critique même avec les morts je ne mets
pas aimé ce film non et je ne pense pas
que ça soit le meilleur film de Claude
Chabrol quant à Arnaud Montebourg
aujourd'hui artisan de la rénovation il
tente de policer son image une nouvelle
ère s'ouvre à lui avec peut-être un peu
moins de bons mots et de formule choc
une chèvre pourrait être élue avec un
institut UMP à Neuilly-sur-Seine
faire une Tarnaud bonsoir C'est à vous
d'interroger Arnaud Montebourg bonsoir
alors est-ce que c'est fini ce temps
d'Arnaud Montebourg dans le rôle du
procureur est-ce qu'il y a un véritable
changement d'image que vous essayez
d'instaurer écoutez non d'abord moi je
reste intransigeant vous savez procureur
que ça veut dire moi je suis pas
procureur je n'ai dressé aucun échafaud
je n'ai
tué personne
heureusement pour moi et pour eux et je
ne vous dire que ce n'est pas ma
vocation moi je pense que la société
telle qu'elle est et d'abord
irrespirable
personnellement à titre personnel je
pense qu'elle est injuste qu'elle est
elle provoque des mouvements de
répulsion à l'homme que je suis bon donc
moi je suis désolé je n'ai pas
l'habitude de transiger avec des
convictions est-ce que en politique on
peut dire les choses je vais vous dire
j'ai eu 15 procès dans ma vie dans ma
vie publique 10 femmes à dénonciation
U15 il en est encore un là
pourquoi parce que je dis les choses je
dis tous gagné tout de suite
les choses et parfois toute vérité n'est
pas toujours bonne à dire je veux bien
en convenir
par exemple oui c'est vrai mais je
voudrais dire que c'est l'âme d'un
réformateur passionné qui parle voilà la
réformateur je ne veux pas me contenter
je suis entré en politique il y a
maintenant 13 ans j'étais avocat j'ai 10
ans d'expérience professionnelle
derrière moi à l'époque pour changer les
choses donc parfois il faut décrire ces
choses pour pouvoir ensuite les
transformer donc ça demande évidemment
un peu l'intransigeance j'en conviens
mais il faut la conserver peut-être
cette fois sa langue dans sa bouche
de convaincre d'autres qui n'ont pas
votre point de vue de passer des accords
des compromis pour arriver à des
résultats donc c'est peut-être ça
j'allais dire le chemin de l'expérience
mais ce que vous reconnaissez
aujourd'hui que ce caractère
bouillonnant dont je parlais a pu
parfois vous jouez des tours en
politique vous écartez de certaines
décisions stratégiques à la tête du
Parti socialiste
écoutez j'ai été un opposant à
l'immobilisme de mon parti je ne
regrette pas d'avoir été
exigeant sur le sujet non je ne regrette
pas c'est un parcours nécessaire voilà
on dit que à l'été 2009 donc il y a un
peu plus d'un an vous avez traversé une
sorte de dépression politique vous en
aviez marre des intrigues au sein du PS
marre des luttes de courant et que vous
avez pensé à jeter l'éponge c'est vrai
c'est exact à plusieurs reprises c'est
arrivé une fois pendant la faire Chirac
lorsque j'étais député avec 38 autres
députés nous avions signé la mise en
accusation du président de la République
il en manquait encore une 12 et ce sont
mes propres amis les dirigeants de la
gauche à l'époque François Hollande
Jean-Marc Ayrault déjà
Lionel Jospin Premier ministre qui ont
bloqué cette initiative donc je me suis
dit à quoi ça sert et tout ça n'aurait
pas été si grave si nous n'avions pas
été obligés d'aller voter pour Jacques
Chirac un an plus tard quand même
c'était en 2001 donc là j'ai eu un
moment mes proches chez moi
Saône-et-Loire j'ai écouté moi c'est
plus possible je suis plus d'accord en
fait voilà ça arrive l'année dernière
c'est exactement la même chose je me
suis dit ce parti est irréformable je ne
veux pas aller dans un autre parti parce
que je suis socialiste bon voilà donc
j'ai aucune raison donc il n'y a pas
d'autres solutions
Martine Aubry dans le rôle dans les
habits d'une femme qui allait changer
bouleverser le parti
soit on le fait soit je m'en vais je
m'en vais non pas je quitte la l'action
publique j'ai mieux à faire moi j'étais
avocat
passionné j'ai un métier qui me manque
depuis un certain nombre d'années j'ai
connu les difficultés le succès j'ai
tout connu il était hors de question
que le mouvement sur lequel nous avions
un accord politique avec Martine de
changer le parti donc pour changer
ensuite la gauche et donc changer la
France tout cela
vous faites de la politique Arnaud
Montebourg parce que vous estimez que la
société est respirable et vous vous
retrouvez dans un parti irrespirable
est-ce que vous avez eu envie
éventuellement d'aller voir ailleurs non
parce que non je je vous réponds non
parce que un parti ça son action
collective et l'outil de la
transformation donc on a besoin qu'il
soit vivant ou vers sur la société et
qu'il soit en train de muter le Parti
socialiste s'il a c'est le plus le parti
le plus vieux de France s'il a un siècle
derrière lui c'est parce qu'il a muté il
y a eu les congrès difficile des années
20 30 et puis il y a eu l'après-guerre
d'après 58 la Cinquième République et
notamment 72 à chaque fois il y a eu des
mutations très importantes je me suis
battu pour qu'il y ait la méditation et
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire parce que nous avons fait une
révolution démocratique nous avons
confié à des millions de citoyens la
possibilité de se rendre aux urnes de
participer à nos débats et d'investir
avec nous pas à notre place mais avec
nous le candidat qui gagnera et
remplacera qui gagnera l'élection
présidentielle remplacera Monsieur
Sarkozy dans votre parcours il y a une
peut-être une
concession le principe du mandat unique
et donc d'être à la fois maintenant
député et président d'un Conseil Général
pourquoi être venu sur ce principe je
l'ai fait d'abord parce que je voulais
changer
de d'action publique je ne voulais pas
rester dans le magistère de du verbe au
Parlement je voulais
dans la vie
quotidienne et concrète et pouvoir
réaliser des choses et mettre en oeuvre
un certain nombre d'idées donc ça avait
un inconvénient c'est que je donnais le
sentiment de commettre une infraction
par rapport à mes principes mais ma
conviction n'a pas changé et d'ailleurs
je vais mettre fin à cette anomalie
en 2012 Quand on va terminer les mandats
comme d'ailleurs nous avons réussi à
l'imposer à l'ensemble du Parti
socialiste le projet de rénovation c'est
la fin du cumul des mandats pour les
parlementaires les sénateurs les députés
dont je suis donc finalement avec
beaucoup de résistance oui mais cette
maison
là en toute matière j'ai envie de vous
dire mon expérience de non-cumulard
comme de cumula m'a permis d'argumenter
pour faire passer le projet parce que
pour faire passer dans le même sens pas
dans les deux sens dans le même sens
pour faire passer le projet est-ce que
vous ne retombez pas là dans
L'Intransigeant puisque
le nom cumule pourrait éventuellement
faire battre la gauche lors du
remaniement Sénat l'année prochaine je
ne crois pas je crois que le nom cumul
des mandats est une force comme acte
politique et qu'il nous donnera du vent
dans les voiles en plus de celui que
nous avons déjà acquis mais au détriment
de certains barons de votre partie
il faut des baronner quand même un peu
oui oui il faut que la politique
ressemble à la société et nous faut des
jeunes des femmes différentes couleurs
les couleurs de la France on ne peut pas
rester dans une sorte de classe
politique qui serait entre soi il est
temps maintenant d'ouvrir les portes et
les fenêtres donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait le non cumuler les mandats et
d'ailleurs moi-même je pourrais céder la
place dans l'une de mes fonctions à
celui qui ou celle qui pourrait me
succéder il y a des tas de talents qui
Piaf aujourd'hui qui ont envie
de reprendre l'énergie que moi j'avais
quand j'étais jeune
et puis à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur votre
chien de quadra devenu quelqu'un
aujourd'hui
pas encore presque j'allais dire presque
vous avez vous avez raison qui
finalement cette génération qui n'a
jamais accédé au pouvoir c'est pas très
grave d'abord on a accédé au pouvoir on
a on a fait des tas de choses on a
construit moi sur mon territoire nous
avons engagé des beaucoup de choses très
importantes dont je suis fier qui sont
méconnus mais ça n'a pas d'importance
l'essentiel c'est que nous l'ayons
réalisé et tout cela compte dans une vie
publique et ce sont des apprentissages
donc nous serons peut-être prêts pour
exercer des fonctions difficiles ce
n'est pas une génération sacrifiée mais
peut-être une génération frustrée non
une génération en devenir
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que le
candidat
issu des primaires prendra la place de
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012 vous en êtes
aussi sûr je crois que aujourd'hui un
parti socialiste qui enfermait sur ses
150 000 militants ou adhérents ces élus
avec autour de lui des parties plus ou
moins d'accord ne pourrait pas gagner
mais un parti qui rassemble la société
mais en mouvement la société parle avec
la société
sur l'ensemble des grands projets qu'il
veut mener est obligé de dire la vérité
ce qui la vérité de ce qu'il va devoir
faire dans une situation réelle de
contrainte je crois est un parti qui
peut convaincre et qui aura la force et
l'énergie de l'emporter
tu peux votre robe d'avocat de procureur
de tout ce qu'on veut voilà des fois on
va peut-être évoquer pour finir
l'émission deux affaires dont on n'a pas
encore parlé d'abord l'affaire clear
Stream qui va être jugé en appel par une
chambre effectivement Samuel
composé de juges spécialement désigné
pour ce procès en appel est-ce que c'est
la seule solution finalement pour juger
cette affaire dans des délais
raisonnables en tout cas c'est
l'argument avancé c'est une manipulation
de
du pouvoir politique pour faire
condamner monsieur de Villepin moi je ne
suis pas villepini je ne suis pas
d'accord et je n'étais pas d'accord avec
ces orientations politiques mais je le
défends par principe parce que il est
victime d'une manipulation judiciaire où
on utilise les organes de la justice
pour faire
condamner à rival politique donc la
justice est utilisée à des fins
politiques c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure finalement on entre dans le
champ de l'arbitraire c'est comme ça que
l'affaire Calas est née on a condamné
Jean Callas parce qu'il était Hugo et
protestant non pas parce qu'il était
coupable et bien on fait la même chose
avec des rivaux politiques ou des gens
qui ont le malheur d'appartenir à une
ethnie indésirable qui s'appelle les
Roms même s'ils sont innocents on va les
juger d'ores et déjà coupable parce que
ce sont des Roms et à l'inverse quand
vous avez besoin d'avoir une justice
clémente vous organisez des systèmes de
protection pour des ministres qui ont
commis des indicateurs comme Monsieur
verte monsieur woert a quand même
quand il était ministre du Budget
distribué des passes droits fiscaux
contre de l'argent pour son parti
politique et pour lui-même et son action
politique contre une embauche de sa
femme contre des légions d'honneur il a
bradé le patrimoine de l'État assez
riche d'amis de Compiègne tout ça il y a
même pas un juge d'instruction qui est
désigné si c'était moi qui avait fait ça
madame mais il y a longtemps que je
serai dans un cul de basse fosse de la
République je croupirais en prison
pourquoi parce que on le protège on va
chercher les services secrets contre
journaliste qui ose enquêter contre ce
pauvre verte on va chercher on va
chercher les procureurs aux ordres qui
découpent et saucissonnent les
procédures organisent la confusion pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'affaires est-ce que
vous allez faire de plus que Monsieur
Eric verte devrait être devant la cour
du 6 de la République sans délai avec
ses avocats pour défendre son honneur
comme tout ministre
ça fait combien de mois que ça dure que
le procureur aujourd'hui vous savez ce
qu'il fait le procureur courroie qui
rend des services au pouvoir qui
d'ailleurs n'a pas beaucoup de
conscience comme magistrat n'a toujours
pas toujours pas saisir juste
d'instruction indépendant pourquoi s'il
y a juste d'instruction indépendant il
va mettre en examen monsieur meurt
pourquoi parce que les chars sont
considérables courroie
je ne sais pas à quoi il sert puisque
pour le moment garde tout pour lui et
que il ne poursuit personne vous avez
remarqué il ne poursuit finalement que
les témoins qu'il embarrassent alors il
reste une minute pour évoquer la seconde
affaire de justice Perrine que vous
vouliez évoquer exactement l'affaire
tapis là aussi vous allez j'imagine
parler de justice à double vitesse à
double tranchant mais est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce si difficile pour des
parlementaires et je pense par exemple à
Jérôme Cahuzac le présent socialiste de
la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée d'avoir des éléments
d'obtenir les des éléments chiffrés pour
connaître le véritable chiffre dans
cette affaire
moi je suis désolé je milite depuis des
années pour une sixième république je
considère que dans la sixième république
la règle ce sera l'information libre
accès pour les citoyens les journalistes
sauf exception secret défense secrète
fabrication secret de l'enquête etc là
il n'y a aucune raison que nous n'ayons
pas accès à cette information donc vous
savez que dans le système actuel il faut
saisir une commission qui rend des avis
six mois après bon inadmissible donc la
règle contre sanction pénale contre
celui qui s'y opposerait serait voilà
une contre proposition démocratique dans
la Sixième République c'est l'accès à
toute information qui concerne le bien
public l'argent public l'usage des
dépenses publiques etc etc très bien
merci on n'a pas le temps d'évoquer le
procès de Jacques Chirac vous êtes
prononcé vous contre le protocole
d'indemnisation voulu par votre ami le
maire socialiste Bertrand Delanoë merci
Arnaud Montebourg bonsoir à tous